[Music]
in 2013 a team of researchers held a
math test the exam was administered to
over 1,100 American adults and designed
in part to test their ability to
evaluate sets of data hidden among these
math problems were two almost identical
questions both problems used the same
difficult data set and each had one
objectively correct answer the first
asked about the correlation between
rashes and a new skin cream
the second asked about the correlation
between crime rates and gun control
legislation participants with strong
math skills were much more likely to get
the first question correct but despite
being mathematically identical the
results for the second question looked
totally different here math skills
weren't the best predictor of which
participants answered correctly instead
another variable the researchers had
been tracking came into play political
identity participants whose political
beliefs aligned with a correct
interpretation of the data were far more
likely to answer the problem right even
the study's top mathematicians were
forty-five percent more likely to get
the second question wrong when the
correct answer challenged their
political beliefs what is it about
politics that inspires this kind of
illogical error can someone's political
identity actually affect their ability
to process information the answer lies
in a cognitive phenomenon that has
become increasingly visible in public
life partisanship while it's often
invoked in the context of politics
partisanship is more broadly defined as
a strong preference or bias towards any
particular group for
our political ethnic religious and
national identities are all different
forms of partisanship of course
identifying with social groups is an
essential and healthy part of human life
our sense of self is defined not only by
who we are as individuals but also by
the groups we belong to as a result
we're strongly motivated to defend our
groups identities
protecting both our sense of self and
our social communities but this becomes
a problem when the group's beliefs are
at odds with reality imagine watching
your favorite sports team commit a
serious foul you know that's against the
rules but your fellow fans think it's
totally acceptable the tension between
these two incompatible thoughts is
called cognitive dissonance and most
people are driven to resolve this
uncomfortable state of limbo you might
start to blame the referee complain that
the other team started it or even
convinced yourself there was no foul in
the first place in a case like this
people are often more motivated to
maintain a positive relationship with
their group than perceive the world
accurately this behavior is especially
dangerous in politics on an individual
scale allegiance to a party allows
people to create a political identity
and support policies they agree with but
partisan based cognitive dissonance can
lead people to reject evidence that's
inconsistent with the party line or
discredits party leaders and when entire
groups of people revise the facts in
service of partisan beliefs it can lead
to policies that aren't grounded in
truth or reason this problem isn't new
political identities have been around
for centuries but studies show that
partisan polarization has increased
dramatically in the last few decades one
theory explaining this increase is the
trend towards clustering geographically
in like-minded communities another is
the growing tendency to rely on partisan
news or social media bubbles these often
act like
coach Amber's delivering news and ideas
from people with similar views
fortunately cognitive scientists have
uncovered some strategies for resisting
this distortion filter one is to
remember that you're probably more
biased than you think so when you
encounter new information make a
deliberate effort to push through your
initial intuition and evaluate it
analytically in your own groups try to
make fact-checking and questioning
assumptions a valued part of the culture
warning people that they might have been
presented with misinformation can also
help and when you're trying to persuade
someone else affirming their values and
framing the issue in their language can
help make people more receptive we still
have a long way to go before solving the
problem of partisanship but hopefully
these tools can help keep us better
informed and capable of making
evidence-based decisions about our
shared reality an important tool in
fighting echo chambers is learning how
to analyze and dissect what you see on
the internet and on social media how
good are you at separating fact from
fiction
test your skills with these videos
[Music]